how are you doing happy holidays merry
christmas
thank you so much um i'm doing well
happy holidays and merry christmas and
marry everything back to you
um you know all things considered i'm
doing very well
you are and how's the family doing we're
we're
we're holding on we're holding on
yes it is not without challenge but i
i have to say you know the the way that
the
world has responded to this
adversity is inspiring you know we can
do anything if we set our minds to it
i get this i get the sense this year i
mean people were putting up their
christmas trees you know in october
people need this this year so how does
it feel for you
to have an album out that is
contributing to that need
well that was the goal i have to say i
you know
all i wanted i i believe a strong
intention is important at the start of a
creative process
strong attention people feel that and i
wanted this
record to feel like a gift i know it's
in the marketplace and i
want to sell a lot of records like
everybody else i want lots of streams
but
more than anything i wanted at the end
of a hard year
for this to feel like
it was wrapped under their tree with a
little bow or it was you know was the
first night of hanukkah you know came
from
their parents or their grandparents i
because i um people
need a gift right now and uh when it
comes to putting something like this
together
i always say it takes a lot of guts to
do
a christmas album where you put a little
bit of your own in with some classics
that people hold
so close to their heart there is an
immense pressure
to do things a different way when
they're the things that people
love yeah
yes it's you know we towed that line in
a way that makes me really proud with
the first
christmas album and i have to tell you i
all these years
later the things that i hear the most
about in my career
are hamilton right after hamilton
it's my first christmas album simply
christmas which was the first recorded
project i did
post hamilton came out in 2016.
and um people loved it they loved it
because it was different
and it was different from what you hear
in the marketplace but it honored
tradition and we thought a lot about
that making that record so this really
is
you know the 2.0 version of that this
project is more joyful
and is more sonically robust than that
first project
but i had gone through that process
making that first one
uh holidays are all about the family
this album is all about the family
nicolette's on it with you
was that did you have to convince or how
did that conversation
happen were you both just like sitting
there and decided yeah let's just do it
how did that happen
we um i
i come up with the crazy ideas for us to
collaborate because i love
singing with my wife um our voices
almost fell in love before we did you
know our voices blended so well together
and even to this day
no matter how upset she gets at me no
matter how much she dislikes me
on any given moment our voices still
love each other so i i had the idea
because i wanted to expand
that that table like because we're uh
we're a multi-faith
family like so many of our families and
hanukkah is something that we
um observe as a family as well as the
christmas
christmas holiday high holy holiday and
the christmas traditions
so and just wanting to have this project
represent um a more
a holiday that looks a lot closer to um
the way we celebrate you know to make it
we decided to include
um this hanukkah song on the record in
hebrew
and the response to that i have to tell
you is almost you know
larger than anything else so far people
are really loving it that's incredible
having
both of you having that sort of broadway
background i imagine there's a scent
there's
like who's the more perfectionist of the
two of you
when it comes to a yeah okay absolutely
that's why she doesn't like to sing with
me because nicolette wants to
first she wants to you know really
really
make all the decisions before we go on
stage she's a brilliant performer you
know
that process works for her i'm a little
more loose with mine i'm a little more
loosey-goosey and so
it drives her if i were to if i were to
ask nicolette whether this year you were
on the nice list or the naughty list
what would she
say oh she'd say nice list
we had no yeah we men this thing we
recognized early that this thing was
going to
either bring us closer or pull us apart
it's just you know it's the outside
pressure
you know this is this has been a
challenge like
nothing else we've ever faced and so we
really have worked on our friendship we
doubled down
on friendship this year and on kindness
because
um there were plenty of things plenty of
outside forces
weighing in on us and our family we
decided not to destroy ourselves from
the inside so
nice list for sure and congratulations
uh you guys just announced you have
another baby
yeah so very nice list very nice list
i had some uh perks around here no we we
um
we're very excited we have a little boy
on the way and um
yeah for for all of the
for all that 2020 has thrown at us
um we also can't deny the the beautiful
bits
and the the
you know as small as so many as our
lives
have gotten um because we are confined
in so many ways
to our houses and the way we never have
been before so our worlds have all
gotten
smaller but maybe like the
interiors have we found new rooms
and new sort of you know our homes have
gotten bigger
in our hearts in some way you know they
take up more room
our families take up more space uh
when uh when we were expecting our first
um
i know my girl over the holidays
while pregnant the sort of line you have
to walk is
while she was pregnant things change and
things that used to smell good smell bad
things that used to taste good taste bad
and that's a dangerous thing going into
the holidays
oh yes let me tell you i
you you know the the thing that makes
nicolette
more upset almost than anything is when
i decide to make a tuna fish sandwich i
mean like that is for her right now that
is
it's like a it's it's an attack on her
to put tuna on top of my pasta or tuna
on a salad she is like
why do you hate me to deserve
the attack of the tuna salad that's true
uh
i love it um when it comes to hamilton
when did you or who told
you the numbers that it got on disney
because they're astronomical
um who told me my my agents you know my
my team they kind of monitored that that
stuff
but i didn't need them to tell me that
because i had i have to tell you
of all the things that i've done even
while i was doing hamilton you have to
imagine you know after a show
i so after like a killer show i just
performed for 300 people
the best night of my life in the richard
rodgers theater
1300 people saw it and i might get 50
if on a good night 50 people hit me up
online and say wow i was there tonight
it was great
never in my life have i gotten 1500
tweets thousands of tweets i was getting
you know when that thing
the weekend that it first premiered
thomas kale our director
told me something a few days before
premiere he said leslie
do you realize that this weekend more
people are going to see you this weekend
in this show than saw the entire run on
broadway
so that's hard to wrap your mind around
but um
it's it's also a wonderful thing because
the messages of the show that i believe
in so much and the power of the show
has been uh just shot out there
and and it's you know it's reached
exponential numbers numbers it would
take
years and years to run on broadway to
reach the amount of people
we've been able to reach on the disney
plus platform and you know what show
business is like when you have something
that is that kind of property that
is that successful they start thinking
what else can we do with it and i know
lin-manuel had said
that doing a sort of filmic version of
hamilton is difficult because it's hard
to stick the landing with something like
that
but they've done it within the heights
and there's still talk there's still
people that think that there's another
phase for hamilton what are your
thoughts
on it taking sort of another step into
the sort of theatrical world
of film oh i think it's it's possible
we've seen other shows do that
other really successful shows do that um
off the top of my head rent cats
um les mis you know so it's it's
certainly possible when the time is
right
um i trust lynn
and tom mchale and jeffrey
um more than i trust most
creatives you know i think they're gonna
do what's best for the show
and they're gonna do uh they're gonna
make make those moves when the time is
right for sure
and uh working with sia in uh she put
this whole thing together with music
what was that experience like
oh it was i yeah i went to we we
affectionately referred to that summer
as camp cia yeah me kate hudson and
maddie would go
we rehearsed for weeks you never
rehearsed for a movie like that we would
just go we'd have our dance rehearsals
our singing classes our acting
rehearsals
um and it was sia really just um
you know she's a visionary it takes a
second to
you know to really get on board to get
in line with the vision
because no people don't think like sia
we don't takes a second to see what she
sees
um but uh i had the time
of my life and we you know she's become
a dear friend and collaborator ever
since
and will we get to hear kate sing oh
yeah
beautifully yes you'll be i think
pleasantly surprised for anybody that's
never heard kate saying
she's um she's beautiful in this film
really
and it's an ambitious movie so it took
them a while in the editing room to get
it right
i think they've gotten it right i saw a
recent cut and it's it's really well
done